growing up in poverty and mom was on
welfare for over ten years and but she
never let any of that affect her in a
negative way so you worry about a
problem so here worrying and all the
stuff also the problem solved all that
anguish for nothing see the physical
application of karate really is the
smallest part of it and there's this one
Indian kid who just didn't like me and
everyday he chased me home from school I
must have a direction for me to get up
in the morning I got to know what it is
that I want to do so all four of us
fight my three students win and I lose
anything you work toward there are
always obstacles obstacles in the way
he's an American martial artist actor
and film producer after serving in the
United States Air Force he began his
rise to fame as a martial artist he
appeared in a number of action films and
had the starring role in the TV series
Walker Texas Ranger
he's Chuck Norris and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success growing up
in poverty and mom was on welfare for
over ten years and but she never let any
of that affect her in a negative way she
always kept a very positive image about
life saying that we may be poor but
we're rich in love and I've always
remembered that and she's always said
that and always kept a positive attitude
about life and that kind of carried off
in me too and I think that was some of
the success in my life has always kept a
positive attitude about whatever it was
I was pursuing Chuck Norris Chuck
Norris's tears pure cancer
too bad he never cries error
you is that true you don't worry about
things no because it doesn't do any good
thing is let's say you worry about a
problem so here worrying and all the
stuff also the problem solved all that
anguish for nothing you know the thing
is worry doesn't solve a problem and
actually hinders the problem what you've
got to do is try to find ways of solving
that solution and or that problem
finding a solution for the problem and
if you do then then you don't have time
to worry about it you're able to live by
that oh well believe me I you know if
from the book as you know I've gone
through a lot of ups and downs that
people see strictly my success but they
don't know where I came from a kid who
grew up in the back hills of Oklahoma
it was totally non-athletic and I won
the world karate championship and the
kid who was extremely shy in school
who'd never even had never even done a
high school play or a book report and
now I'm doing this the thing is you find
formulas you find things that will help
you work for what you want Chuck Norris
is currently suing NBC claiming law and
order are trademarked names for his left
and right leg
you see the physical application of
karate really is is the smallest part of
it most people think of christ' rickly
as a physical application but what it
does for you mentally psychologically
and emotionally is much more important
than what the physical attributes can be
for instance we we teach success
orientation positive minded type goals
because many students we could get it to
our school come in there and they're in
a very negative train of thought I can't
do this I can't do that I can't
accomplish things and what we try to do
as teachers is to push out all the
negative thoughts and replant positive
ideas of what you can do what you can
accomplish in life and we set formulas
for them which is very good which works
in all areas of life not strictly karate
but college training or whatever and and
that in the formula that I emphasize is
that whatever goal you set for yourself
which we all do as we as we get into the
adult world we all set goals for
ourselves the first thing you must have
is a mental image in your mind of what
it is that you want to accomplish like
you're going to college now you know
what in your mind of what it is that you
want to achieve secondly you must be
determined and persistent enough to
stick with it long enough now this word
a lot of people fail because whether
you're going through college teach your
masters or whatever you're gonna hit
obstacles and root you know it gets
tough at times and a lot of times people
will quit because of the because of
these obstacles in the way and we always
emphasize the fact that you must be
determined to overcome each obstacle and
root and then if you'll study or train
whatever it may be
accordingly there's done a thing in the
world that you cannot it yes that's one
of my favorites here when the boogie man
goes to sleep every night he checks his
closet for Chuck Norris
there is a scene in there where you
talked about bullies and running from
danger and things like that when you
were trying to help this kid yeah what
happens is this boy is being harassed by
the neighborhood bully and his father is
encouraging his son to beat up this
little boy mm-hmm and I wrote this scene
you know I wrote this particular scene
in the script and I was trying to think
what can I write to encourage this boy
to handle this situation you know with
this bully in the neighborhood and I'm
and I'm spending days trying to hear
what can I say to boy and finally I came
up the answer and it was a situation
that I as a child had encountered about
his age I went to a school in Arizona
that was mostly Indians from the
reservation and there's this one Indian
kid who just didn't like me and everyday
he chased me home from school and and
I'd had to run by this gas station in
this mechanic could watch me being
chased by this Indian kid every day and
finally he just couldn't handle it
anymore and he stopped me and maybe
faced this boy and I told myself you
know I'm I was told I'm scared and and
he says well and what he said to me
which is feel still true which I
remember is that he says you know that
running from your fear is more painful
than facing it and that's something I've
always remembered and in this what I
relate to this boy and of course
eventually he has to face this fear in
the film and fine print on the last page
of the Guinness Book of record of will
records it notes that all world records
are held by Chuck Norris and those
listed in the book are simply the
closest anyone else has ever gotten yeah
again you learn philosophies as you go
from experiences in life you start
learning philosophies and things that
will help you work like for me I'm very
goal-oriented I have not I must have a
direction for me to get up in the
morning I got to know what it is that I
want to do and it's like when I was a
karate fighter all I wanted to do was
win a local karate tournament in LA and
once I wanted Wow how about the state
title so the state title became the next
goal and then when I won that there was
a national international in the world if
I said I wanted to be the world champion
when I first started fighting it was too
far beyond my conception but I but I had
realistic goals goals that I felt in my
heart I could achieve the same thing in
the movie business you know I I had no
idea I'd be wiser day when I first
started I just wanted to do a movie
anything just to try to get some
experience when Chuck North citizens his
taxes he sends blank forms and includes
only a picture of himself crouched and
ready to attack Chuck Norris has never
had to pay taxes ever
my first tournament was in Salt Lake
City Utah
I take three of my students and myself
we drive 16 hours to get to Salt Lake
City to compete in this tournament so
all for for spite my three students win
and I lose so I Drive back while they
held the trophies you know but you know
interesting how philosophies are
developed because on the way back I'm
thinking well how come I you know I
didn't win what was it I did that it
made me lose and so I started going
through the the fight in my mind and I
said okay I understand what I did wrong
and I said okay I may make a mistake
again but I'm not gonna make the same
mistake or the same loss again and so
philosophies are developed through this
here and as I tell my key students I
said don't they time you ever lose at
anything is when you don't learn from
that experience
because that's what life is life is full
of experiences and if you learn from
them you're going to grow Chuck Norris
doesn't churn butter
he roundhouse kicks the cows and the
butter comes straight out
anything you work toward there are
always obstacles obstacles in the way
and that's when you either quit or you
continue on and that's when I say
discontinued on you overcome that
obstacle and route to your goal because
you never know which is the last
obstacle that's gonna try to stop you
and if you stop that could have been the
last obstacle in route to your success
Chuck Norris once shot down a German
fighter plane with his finger by yelling
bang jock and his team of Texas Rangers
beat the bad guys from 1993 till 2000
in fact CBS wanted to go another two
years on the series and I probably would
have considered that except that my wife
was pregnant with our twins at that
particular time toward the end of the
eighth season and I knew that I couldn't
do a series and take care of my wife
during her pregnancy so I know it's time
to call him into it rather than being
birth birth like a normal child Chuck
Norris instead decided to push his way
out punch his way out
it's like when I was a fighter you know
I'd be walking down the aisle to the
ring and I'd be shaking hands and you
know and send hello to everybody but
once I walked into the ring my whole
demeanor changed because there is a good
man across the ring is I'm knock my
block off and so I had to change my
attitude I had to become much more
aggressive and almost animalistic and
when I fought him they were entered the
fight was over then I'd go back to more
of a mild individual that's basically
the philosophy my movies the guy who
isn't looking for trouble tries to avoid
it and when he's put into position that
he's got to face it like we would have
to do in real life
then he becomes that person to deal with
that situation there are no steroids in
baseball only players Chuck Norrises
breathed on
believe me suddenly these are beats got
screenplay writers here the martial arts
changed my whole life I was a very shy
kid growing up and I had a I was
terrified to get up in front of anyone
and talk all through high school I never
once got in front of a class to give a
book report or anything when the teacher
called me up and say my real name is
Carlos by the way that and but anyway
they'd get him say would you come up and
give a book report I'd be sitting at my
desk and I go and my face to turn beet
red from embarrassment but I thought if
I got up there I'd be more embarrassed
so I went through that very insecure
time in my life
then when I went to Korea at the age of
19 and being attained my black belt I
came back to the States
now I'm 22 years old and I'm stationed
in March Air Force Base in Riverside
California and I thought and so I was
doing my martial arts now this is
1961-62
and no one really knew anything about
the martial arts at that time and so I'm
doing my kicks and punches and all that
and all the GIS on the base and watch me
and say will you teach me that teach me
teach us that stuff I thought maybe I'll
start a club on the base so I decided to
give a demonstration at the gym on the
base and I'll never forget this
this little 47 years ago and that night
I sent out notices to everybody that I'm
gonna give a demonstration and I thought
well I might have to give a talk and I'm
22 years old and never done this in my
life so I wrote out about half page
speech and I memorized this thing for
two weeks I could say it forwards
backwards sideways whatever the night of
the demonstration I walk into the gym
and the microphones laying on the floor
and I walk up I pick up the microphone
and I say good evening ladies and
gentlemen my name is Chuck Norris and I
like to welcome you here tonight that's
the last thing I remember the next thing
I remember I'm walking out into the
middle of the gym to do my demonstration
and as I'm walking out there on
thinking did I finish my speech or did I
just lay the microphone down well to
this day I still don't really know but
what was important for me at that time
it crack the egg of insecurity that I
carried around for 22 years and then I
kept forcing myself until that egg
cracked open and of course the results
of all that is becoming an actor you
know starting a foundation with
kickstart kids which is the love of my
life now I'm teaching the martial arts
in the inner city schools in the middle
schools again using the martial art
martial arts as a tool to help these
kids develop the security and themselves
that I lacked as a youngster and helping
them believe in themselves that they can
accomplish anything they want in their
life if they're willing to pay the price
for and that's hard work and dedication
that's the secret to being successful in
your life and number 10 is when Chuck
Norris does push-ups he doesn't push
himself up he pushes the earth down
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this beauty because oguns Alice
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Chuck Norris is top ten
rules meant the most to you and why
leave it in the comments and I will join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon
you took acting classes yeah I took
acting classes even in my acting classes
I couldn't get a part yeah how'd you
break through I don't know it's just
determination you know and they're not
giving up and resistance and the goals I
wanted in the in the karate world I bet
you know in the world title and my
schools and I was trying to decide what
new energy I want to drink know where I
wanted to direct my energies at and
Steve McQueen who was one of my students
at the time suggested the acting field
and I just finished a movie with Bruce
Lee called returned the dragon so I
decided to have it pursue pursue that if
you ever made a mistake of course you
have we all have many times it's hard to
face up to that mistake because it means
you may be laughed at or punished when
you do face up to your mistake and know
you'll never do it again can you become
a much stronger person they wanted to
put Chuck Norrises face on Mount
Rushmore
but the granite wasn't hard enough for
his beard yeah